the national hockey league has pulled
the plug on its players taking part in
the beijing olympics next month the
league made the official announcement
amid a covet 19 outbreak that has led to
a temporary suspension of the season by
skipping the olympic games the league
will now use the originally scheduled
break to make up missing games so to
discuss this further i want to bring in
sean shapiro of the athletic sean great
to speak with you i feel like this
decision was inevitable because first
the nhl suspended games between canadian
teams and american teams then it's
suspended games until after christmas
and now they finally made a decision on
not attending the beijing olympics who's
relieved by this decision who's
frustrated by it
yeah i mean the official announcement
came down today but this is kind of one
of those things where we've seen the
writing on the wall for i want to say a
couple weeks now with just we've seen
code related
schedule schedule issues and everything
like that across the league even more so
in the past four to five days
obviously
nhl owners and teams in general
um have never
it's never really been
much of their ideal to send the players
to the olympics um as we saw the players
weren't at the 2000 we're not at the
2000 nhl players are not at the 2018
olympics because essentially the owners
and the in the teams kind of won in that
collective bargaining agreement players
pushed really hard to get back to get
the olympics back into this respective
collected bargaining agreement and
that's why so
by the players not going to the olympics
obviously there's a lot of players that
are essentially bummed out about this
there's players who
you look at some guys who
for sidney crosby is one that comes to
mind who was on that this probably was
going to be his last chance to play in
the olympics even though the nhl
is still on the dock to go in 2026
probably not going to happen at that
point for him so the player perspective
that's where more the frustration is um
i think there's a stive there's
definitely a sigh of relief
for
the teams and the owners and everything
like that who now
don't have to go through a three-week
break
don't have to go through a three-week
break in this season and they get a
little bit of that flexibility to try
and make up some of these lost games it
won't be the easiest thing to do it's
definitely going to be quite the
juggling act because
rescheduling games is never the easiest
thing but the owners and and the owners
and the teams
bit relieved today definitely really
does this all came out players obviously
frustrated but yeah i think at the end
of the day players were also getting to
the point of
they started to wonder if it was worth
it as well which is why ultimately it
became a joint decision from the league
and the players association which i
think is important to remember on this
it wasn't as simple
so and i imagine rescheduling the games
when you share an arena is also going to
be a challenge as well for a lot of
these teams
are owners in the league being
unnecessarily short-sighted when they
see the olympics as intrusive and a risk
to their business i mean it does
basically spread the sport of hockey
build up that good will with viewers
around the world
yeah it's kind of it's kind of a
just i guess it's you kind of weigh
different options there for on one hand
if you look from the owner perspective
and completely justified anything about
is
if you're going to take or we do we
really want to take a three-week break
for games that are essentially going to
be played at three in the morning
um the three in the morning are our time
and well obviously it's great for the
game and it's great for to see these
best on best tournaments from a business
standpoint i don't know how much
uh the owner of the
wings or the tampa bay lightning get
from
letting their players go playing a game
that's played at 3m local time um i i
i've always felt that
there's
there there should be the olympic kind
of best on best set up there is great
for the sport i think it's created some
great memories
i think from a league perspective i
think this is the type of thing that
also leads to some other conversations
that they should probably have with the
international olympic committee that
would allow them to work better in
tandem because one thing i think that we
often forget about is the ioc is
incredibly restrictive with their rights
and who and and everything like that so
every one of the big one of the best
moments in
hockey history is sydney crosby's golden
goal in vancouver the nhl does not have
the right it does not have the rights
from the ioc to use that clip to promote
you can't walk and so it's little things
like that where i certainly understand
where the nhl comes from and that
perspective of if the ioc is not going
to
kind of give a little bit back to make
it to help better promote your game
why are you going to basically promote
their events so i think it's kind of
it's more nuanced than
should they or shouldn't they go it's
how do we go in the future and they
definitely they will go in 2020 2026 the
players um
in the league have that agreement but as
they move forward i'm sure the nhl and
the ioc will want to have some
conversations how can we actually work
in tandem on this because yeah right now
it's that's that's always been kind of
one of the bigger issues to me is they
don't promote each other enough beyond
just the fact it's hockey yeah they're
kind of working at cross purposes and i
i did not realize that idea that they
didn't have the rights to some of those
highlights that's really interesting
something else that you've been writing
about on the athletic sean is how the
nhl corporate business has really boomed
and lifted the league
during the pandemic why is hockey
related revenue on track to reach 5.2
billion dollars this season that that
seems incredible to me
yeah and it's i mean it's even more
incredible when you think about it that
that's above the pre pre-pandemic number
5.1 from the last 5.1 billion from the
last season um hockey has always been a
gate driven league and by great drive
and i mean
more than
about 60 percent of our revenue was
coming from tickets food and beverage at
games basically um revenue related to
people at the game and one of the things
that's really taken a step forward for
the league within the last two within
the last 12 months specifically is how
much corporate business has really
invested in the sport and one of the
biggest flash points
for that was the new nhl tv deal with
espn and turner sports they went from a
10-year deal with nbc's with nbc
universal to
um the two national tv deals with turner
and the walt disney company and that was
kind of a um
that kind of raised the
value of the nhl if you're if you're
looking at if you're looking at sponsors
like for example one that recently uh
partnered with the nhl is a comp is
chipotle
i just know this because chipotle is not
sponsored with any other pro sports like
part of the reason was that was they
looked at the fact that the nhl is on
espn the nhl is on turner they looked at
it as this valuations going there and
then the other thing that's really that
that people people are trying to be
smarter and savvier with their money and
they are also noticing now that
it is still evil prices and demand have
gone up to partner with the nhl it still
is on average considerably less
expensive for an advertiser or a
corporate sponsor to
promote to to sponsor something in hl
compared to the mba interesting
yeah so
so they're seeing so brands are seeing
a much larger return of investment well
the mba may have more viewers or the nfl
definitely has more viewers
you may not be reaching the same amount
of people but the cost the cost that
people the cost that brands are seeing
by getting with the nhl compared to
having to pay more with the other ones
they're starting to see okay this is
this is a smart business decision the
nhl is kind of riding that wave right
now okay so it's a return on investment
and relative value compared to some of
the more popular leagues
still at the same time when it comes to
this new contract this new streaming
deal with espn it can be complicated for
for fans who don't attend the game in
person to be able to find the right game
it's not often shown on espn when it is
on espn plus that's an added layer of
complication have the new streaming
rights made things overly complicated
for viewers
it's definitely
if you are a traditional north american
sports fan it is kind of been a bit of a
sticker shock type moment where
games on esp oh well it's a national tv
game when really it's a national
streamed game um and so it's kind of
been a bit of a sticker shock for the
traditional north american fan um in
general though it's kind of where we're
going to be going with sports deals in
the future we've seen it within the
united states you look at the english
premier league syria you look at
international soccer leagues and so much
of that is built around these streaming
deals and the espn nhl deal is kind of
the first foray into a north american
domestic league that's really going into
that um and even the new nfl deal that
that
they sign which i believe starts in two
years as i believe when it starts but
there's going to be an exclusive amazon
game and people are going to be have to
to stream to watch that nfl game we'll
have to get amazon prime or whatever
whichever one it is yeah um so this it's
kind of it's definitely um
led to some complications and
frustrations there's there definitely
could have been much better messaging
from the league in the teams i believe
in better communicating this but at the
end of the day it's also kind of we'll
look at this four or five years from now
and realize this was all just kind of
the first step in
this is where we're going with all of
these tv deals because
as people as
as people try to beef up and build their
streaming services as something to build
more subscribers these are the type of
deals they're going to be after whether
it's the espn pluses or the paramount
pluses or the peacocks or whatever it is
really interesting that the nhl is a bit
ahead of the curve here than uh when it
comes to the professional sports leagues
and coming up with these kinds of
streaming deals sean really appreciate
your joining us and giving us your
perspective
you